et pour en parler nous recevons un thème
nafti essayiste et auteur du livre de la
révolution à la restauration voit la
tunisie chez aux éditions riveneuve
bonjour merci d'être sur notre plateau
alors la tunisie qui a célébré donc hier
le neuvième anniversaire de la
révolution du jasmin qui a chassé du
pouvoir les abidine ben ali aujourd'hui
nous avons un nouveau pouvoir nous avons
un nouveau président caisse aride et un
gouvernement qui n'est toujours pas fait
on sait que le gouvernement était
présente et enfin que le premier
ministre a présenté un gouvernement mais
il n'a pas obtenu d'accord vendredi
alors comment expliquer justement le
rejet de cette proposition alors les
élections législatives du 6 octobre 2019
ont abouti au parlement le plus
fragmenté de l'histoire de la tunisie
le premier groupe parlementaire navx
n'avait que peu près le quart de
l'assemblée et ils n'ont pu compter que
leur que sur leurs fidèles alliés de la
coalition de la dignité donc à eux deux
ils arrivent et ils sont arrivés à 72
députés dont on était loin des 109
c'était prévisible bons qu'ils ont
essayé de discuter notamment avec mêmes
ils ne virent pas lui qui est arrivé
deuxième aux présidentielles et qu'il y
avait un groupe parlementaire d'une
quarantaine de députés mais bon
manifestement ils se sont pas accordés
sur une marche à suivre et on a abouti à
ce résultat
donc là bon l'initiative revient au
président de la république mais on a
toujours la même composition du
parlement donc les tractations vont être
difficiles alors mais le parlement il
est plus dominé par le parti annahda
aujourd'hui en tunisie et le
gouvernement qui a été présentée ne va
pas dans les aspirations du parlement
qu'est ce qui bloque réellement ce qui
bloque c'est une question arithmétique
c'est à dire que n'a par exemple en 2011
ils étaient arrivés premiers comme en
2019 en 2011 il avait prise avec 89
députés dont killer manqué vingt sièges
pour atteindre la majorité absolue
heidi shawky doublé leur score on n'est
pas du tout dans le même rapport de
force il n'ya pas d'hégémonie sur sur le
parlement et ce qui fait que
il va falloir ménager les
susceptibilités les attentes des uns et
des autres le problème est plus due à la
composition de ce parlement totalement
fragmentée que canardo par le premier
parti quand il ya même pas le quart de
l'assemblée peut difficilement
constituer une majorité
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant si
jamais et là je sais qu'il ya des
concertations
le président de la république à cinq
jours quels sont les scénarios possibles
alors le problème c'est que il ya eu
facilement à ce front du refus
d'à-peu-près 130 députés
donc dès qu'on parlementaires différents
qui font des sociaux-démocrates data ya
des nationalistes arabes de chat à al
qods qui sont libéraux aop dell qui est
le une sorte de l'émanation du parti de
ben ali
donc ce sont des oppositions très
disparates qui se sont accordés à faire
chuter un gouvernement mais il va être
difficile de les mettre d'accord
donc ça y est tu peux soit choisir une
personnalité indépendante qui arrive à
contenter tout le monde donc qui est pas
clairement identifiés dans un camp ça
c'est possible
certains partis
ont dit clairement qu'ils étaient prêts
à renoncer à certaines de leurs
exigences
parce que c'est sarah il dispose de deux
armes
la première arme c'est sa popularité il
a été élu à plus de 72%
ça c'est un petit peu érodés mais il
jouit d'une popularité extraordinaire
highside aux dernières élections
parlementaires
aux dernières législatives n'a pas
présenté de députés dont il n'y a pas de
majorité présidentielle si lee addy
solution plusieurs députés gérer même
plus de la moitié des députés ne sont
pas assuré d'être réélu donc qu'il faut
tout faire pour éviter de repasser par
les urnes et de perdre de perdre leur
leurs sièges et surtout l'immunité qui
va avec parce qu'il ya un certain nombre
de députés qui ont de graves problèmes
de la faim des déboires avec la justice
mais qui agissez dès la deuxième arme
on dispose donc c'est beaucoup il va là
il ya cette arme là qui est la
popularité la deuxième marque donc c'est
la dissolution qui pourraient balayer
toute cette classe politique pour des
députés compatible avec le président de
la république
dernière question ne reste vraiment très
très peu de temps on l'a dit un c'est le
neuvième anniversaire de cette
révolution quel bilan faites vous
aujourd'hui sur la tunisie je pense que
la tunisie malgré toutes les difficultés
et sur le chemin de la démocratie que
les tunisiens qui souffrent énormément
notamment de cette classe politique et
de la crise économique
ben quand on leur a demandé aux
dernières élections si vous voulez
revenir à l'ancien régime puisqu'il y
avait clairement cette offre-là de
revenir l'ancien régime ils ont
clairement refusé
donc ils y tiennent pour combien de
temps seul l'avenir nous le dira mais
pour l'instant ils sont convaincus que
malgré tout la révolution est meilleur
que le régime qui avait avant voilà sur
sur un nouveau un nouveau départ donc la
tunisie l'actualité tunisienne que l'on
voit bien évidemment suivre en tout cas
merci beaucoup arrêtent m
nafti d'avoir répondu à nos questions
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes essayiste et
auteur du livre de la révolution à la
restauration où va la tunisie aux
éditions riveneuve